nato secretary general jens stoltenberg
welcoming the ambassadors of the two
countries that want to become the newest
members to join an alliance which
currently has 30 members
the ambassadors had with them their
formal letters of application
this moment marking a radical change in
opinion in the two nordic nations that
has long cherished their non-aligned
status
a change that's taken place in a period
of less than three months since russia
invaded ukraine
every nation has the right to choose its
own path
you have both made your choice of the
thorough democratic processes
and i warmly welcome
the requests by finland and sweden to
join nato
you are
our closest partners
and your membership
in nato would increase our shared
security of the current nato members 29
out of 30 strongly support sweden and
finland's membership they both have
sophisticated armies substantial fleets
of aircraft and both have served
alongside nato forces in the balkans and
afghanistan
the leader of one nato member though has
objections turkey's president erdogan
accuses both countries of harboring
terrorists in particular kurdish
nationalist groups the us is confident
that turkey can be persuaded and that's
why the u.s secretary of state will be
meeting his turkish counterparts soon at
the u.n in new york if turkey does
change its position the two countries
could be sitting around the nato table
as invitee nations at a summit at the
end of june
formal ratification though will take
several months more
in a significant move the u.s aircraft
carrier the uss harry truman and its
strike group have been moved in recent
hours to the baltic sea
finland and sweden are not yet members
covered by nato's security guarantees
but its presence is a clear sign to
russia if it was considering any
response to the latest developments
james bay's al jazeera at nato
headquarters in brussels